you
[Music]
hi hello everyone hi I'm Elsa
Tacomas I'm a researcher here at the the
LTC under MS Rai and I'm gonna be
turning the session this afternoon are
we gonna have three awesome talks and
and we're gonna start with Kristin and
she's going to be talking about
adverbial causal modifiers in the lingo
grammar matrix so take it away hi today
I'll be presenting an extension to the
lingo grammar matrix that'll allow for
the automatic production of precision
grammars that accommodate adverbial
clause on modifiers so this is a little
bit less of an MLP talk so I'm gonna
start by giving you a background on
precision grammars and the grammar
matrix in particular and then I'll
discuss the typology of clausal
modifiers in the world languages I
introduced you to briefly to our
syntactic analysis and then go through
our development of the library and our
evaluation and error analysis so
precision grammars are bi-directional
grammars that parse and generate
sentences but their strength is that
they produce very precise syntactic and
semantic representations and in our case
the syntactic representations are in the
HT SG formalism and the semantics are
using minimal recursion semantics the
most important thing about these
grammars is that they prioritize
precision meaning we care about what
proportion of our parses are the right
parse rather than being as concerned
with our overall coverage uses for these
grammars include include building
grammars for languages where we don't
necessarily have enough data for
traditional NLP methods but we do have
linguistic information that we can
utilize linguists use these grammars for
hypothesis testing checking their
analyses over a corpus and these are
also useful for finding out what's
actually in your corpus when you run
your corpus through one of these
grammars you might find a phenomenon
that you didn't realize was there or you
might actually find some inconsistencies
either
your data or in your annotation however
these grammars are very expensive and
time-consuming to create so the lingo
grammar matrix is a starter kit for
creating HP SG grammars basically it
elicits information from the user about
the language and then produces grammars
from that so a quick example this is the
word order page on the customization
screen and it asks the user what's the
basic word order of the language is this
subject verb object subject object verb
and so forth
do the determiners come before or after
the noun do auxiliaries come before or
after their verbal complements and then
based on the user's input on this page
and analyses developed based on the type
of literature a precision grammar is
output that can now accommodate that
phenomenon right now the grammar matrix
includes a wide variety of phenomenon
including word order morphology tense
and aspect but previously it did not
accommodate subordinate clauses of any
kind so today we're presenting a library
for adverbial clause all modifiers these
are your subordinate clauses that
present information like time purpose
your basic while because type clauses
and in the world languages these
manifests in a number of ways but follow
three basic patterns typically clausal
modifiers are marked by a free
subordinating morpheme and I'll just use
the word subordinator moving forward and
this is a word like win or tow in the
Japanese example at the top I can point
to that another pattern is subordinator
pairs and we see these very robustly in
Mandarin such as the yin Wei suoi pair
where you have this because subordinator
and the subordinate clause but then in
the matrix clause you have to have this
additional adverb these are also really
common in if-then clauses
cross-linguistically if it's easier to
think of an English example and finally
sometimes subordinate clauses are marked
just with verbal morphology
so the purpose of suffix right here in
this example from Luis sanyo marks that
subordinate clause as a purposes purpose
of clause in addition to these basic
patterns we also see a very wide range
of variation within these clauses and
any given language will probably be
marked by a handful of different
strategies that utilize these
characteristics so these include the
position of the clausal modifier whether
it's before or after the main clause the
whether or not there's a pair whether
there's additional verbal morphology us
you might have a subordinator and then
also a non-finite verb and the
subordinate clause
sometimes the clause is nominal eyes or
the subject is shared
so it's unexpressed in the subordinate
clause but expressed in the main clause
so this is an example like I went to the
store to buy bread where I is the
subject of both classes but unexpressed
in the purpose of clause so in order to
account for the space and analyze this
within the grammar matrix we introduced
two lexical types and two unary rules an
abstract away from the nitty-gritty HPS
G on this slide basically what we've
done is we've created four super types
that account for the basics of each
strategy whether it's a subordinator or
a morphological subordination and then
on to these super types we can add new
features in the subtypes so to account
for all of these characteristics on this
slide we add feature definitions that we
can put into the sub types for each
subordinate clause strategy so for
example we use the post head feature
which is just a boolean feature to
constrain whether the clausal modifier
goes before or after the main clause and
if it's free to go in either place then
we leave that under specified in our
development we use two sets of
development data
sorry about that a quick example of how
we map that map those features onto the
customization page for the user is that
we use an iterator that allows the user
to define as many clausal modifier
strategies as they want so they can have
the purpose of strategy that just uses
the drop subject in the non-finite and
to buy bread and they can use a
different strategy for a because clause
which is marked by a subordinator and
they're free to fill in as many
strategies as they need so when
developing we use two sets of
development data our first stage is
pseudo languages these are languages
with a minimal lexicon that are designed
to capture the typological space so
we'll just use a simple language where
the nouns are called noun 1 noun 2 and
the verbs are called verb 1 verb 2 and
then we capture the type logical space
as best we can by pairing each
subordinator type with each feature so
going back to the previous slide we have
all of these feature values that are
possible on the subordinator types and
we'll test this adposition subordinate
or lexical type with one of the posted
features but if we were to actually test
all of them we'd have a thousand and
eight test languages and that would be
really cumbersome because these aren't
just test instances these are full
languages so the end of this stage we
expect full coverage right we should be
able to capture the typological space by
accounting for every possible
combination of features however we don't
test each feature value just every
feature type after that our second
development set is illustrative
languages and at this point we actually
get involved with natural language it's
a bit Messier because we're testing
interactions that actually occur in real
languages such as subject dropping in
the language various word order patterns
and these interacting phenomenon can
cause complications that weren't
previously tested in the pseudo language
evaluation or pseudo language testing
so we used for real languages that were
selected specifically to illustrate a
particular phenomenon so we used
Mandarin to illustrate the subordinator
pair that I discussed previously Roo Chi
requires that subordinate clauses be
nominal iced German is a v2 language
verbs second language that requires verb
final word order and subordinate clauses
so we tested that and then Wan bhaiyya
is a morph language that marks it's
subordinate clauses morphologically we
tested that as well now at this stage we
discovered one phenomenon that's not
captured in our library and probably
shouldn't be and this is that
subordinate clauses actually have a
different case frame on the objects in
those clauses so a nominative accusative
language will actually have dative case
in the subordinate clause so we decided
that this should actually be treated
separately as a valence change in
operation in another library that we set
aside for future work so we don't expect
full coverage here as those examples
aren't expected to parse so finally we
move on to evaluation and at this stage
we test the type of logical diversity
and reliability of our system by testing
on five held-out languages this is not
just held-out data but these are
languages that we did not consider at
all during development and the way we
construct our test Suites and grammars
is by reading the descriptive grammars
written by failed linguists that have a
lot of very detailed data and prose
descriptions and we develop our test
Suites from that these languages were
selected in a random set a random manner
but required to be genetically in
geographically diverse so if I polled
two indo-european languages off the
shelf I would put them back so that we
represent five distinct language
families here we achieved 88% coverage
and 2% over generation at this point and
that 2% over generation comes from just
one
example parsing and that really shows
our fidelity to precision here as for
our error analysis this hack up this
actually tells us quite a bit about the
library and about the typology of clause
and modifiers so I've broken this into
two categories in scope phenomena and
out of scope phenomena we had one
sentence fail to parse in most attend
due to a constraint in the supertype
that shouldn't have been there should
have been added in the subtype so that's
a bug and it's fixed next we found a bug
in the nominal eyes clauses library
where nominal eyes clauses had a special
head subject rule to allow for that
attachment but did not account for
subject dropping meaning a phenominal
eyes clause didn't have an overt subject
this couldn't parse and it turns out
that it's possible in basque so we
created a rule and inserted that into
the grammar to make sure that that
sentence would parse if that rule was
there next we get to out of scope
phenomena and this is really the
interesting part of error analysis
because we see what didn't come up in
the typological literature that turns
out is out there in the world's
languages our first error came from the
same case change issue that we saw in
Wamba and so I have an example for you
here in this language third person
subjects are marked with accusative case
instead of nominative case in the
subordinate clause and so you see that
here so this wasn't accounted for and we
had one sentence that is grammatical
failed to parse and then one on
grammatical sentence parse and that's
what led to our two percent over
generation the next thing we found in
MIDI is that subordinators actually can
attach to a verb so in the typological
literature we saw the subordinators
attaching either to the sentence on the
outside of the clause or to the verb
phrase intervening between a subject and
verb but we never saw it intervening
between the verb and its object and in
fact in my D it's possible in the
sentence if Opie
fear he should put it on the shelf if
can intervene between bring and beer so
this is easy enough to add now that we
know that it's possible in the world
languages and that'll be part of our
future work and finally we found in
Lavaca live a that the same pair adverb
phenomena that we see in phenomenon
where you have a or that you see in
mandarin where you have a subordinator
in the clausal modifier and an adverb in
the main clause can occur where you have
a morphologically marked subordinate
clause and you still need an adverb in
the main clause so there was only a
brief description of this in the prose
in one example so what we would like to
do is some further investigation and the
typological literature as well as in
that language before adding this
functionality to the library just to
make sure so what we've done today is
we've introduced a new library that now
accommodates one type of subordinate
clause in the grammar matrix so that
these precision grammars can be
automatically produced are there any
questions I don't know yeah so the
question is what do the grammars look
like so we're using the head driven
phrase structure grammar formalism and
this is a lexically driven syntactic
framework and we have a combination of
lexical entries and free structure rules
yeah how much of English prose are you
able to parts now what Rosie is still
missing and are you up to Olive it's
just some other languages you don't do
um that's a great question so the
grammar matrix actually grew out of the
English resource grammar which covers
96% of well-edited English text maybe
it's 94 so that's a very large grammar
we haven't actually tested
this on English like the grammar matrix
outputs on English we are still missing
a number of phenomena a library for a
clausal compliments has just been added
and but there's still more to be done
we don't have relative clauses we don't
have WH questions so we still wouldn't
be quite close to there but that work
has been done on the individual language
level other questions yes oh yeah in
terms of phenomena that are not yet in
the grammar matrix we're still missing
quite a bit so what I would recommend
you do is go to the grammar matrix page
and see what's there and then you should
be able to figure out what's not but
there are lots of new phenomena relative
clauses I think is a next direction
adverbs themselves not adverbial classes
but just adverbs haven't been
implemented yet
[Applause]
Michael's going to be talking about
simple questions nearly solved in your
unbounded and baseline approach it's a
joint work with Lukas little more you
take hi there my name is Michael and I'm
presenting I said simple questions
nearly solved this was undergraduate
research that I did at the Paul G Allen
school okay to give you first a brief
overview over my talk
first we're going to introduce you to
the widely used simple questions
benchmark and then we're going to go
over the contributions this paper is
made on to that benchmark first talking
about that we actually found that
there's an upper bound on this benchmark
and then introducing a simple baseline
method that actually gets
state-of-the-art results and then we'll
conclude that we found that through our
analysis our upper bound it's loose and
that the simple questions data is nearly
solved okay
so first a some background what is a
simple question so for example who wrote
Gulliver's Travels as a simple question
the reason it's a simple questions
because it has one relation one subject
and a simple question stands for a
single relation single subject factoid
question why are these questions
interesting to look at
well they appear often online
specifically Microsoft has them a lot in
their query logs we see them popping up
in weak answers and they're commonly
used that voice assistance yet although
they're very commonly used the most
popular and largest benchmark by
magnitude the state-of-the-art results
on it are only 77% okay so a little bit
more background the simple questions
benchmark
it's the largest simple questions data
set with 108 thousand examples each
example has a question that is labeled
with a subject relation and object and
it has a back-end freebase knowledge
graph which is just the store of facts
and then bringing up an example for that
for example here's the relation and this
is the freebase relation for who wrote
in this context and for goal verse
travels the freebase object has an M ID
and an alias Gulliver's Travels
okay so the first contribution is
introducing an upper bound so the
example and what's really driving this
work is that there's fundamental
contradictions and the simple questions
data set for example who wrote
Gulliver's Travels is referring to the
TV miniseries Gulliver's Travels while
named a character from gobos travels is
referring to her Culver travels book
this shows that the linguistic signal in
these questions does not provide or
provides equal evidence for it being an
either miniseries or a book in both
cases it's not clear ok so how do we how
do we quantify this and get to an upper
bound so a reminder this is the data set
this is the data that we're dealing with
so the first thing we do is we take a
look at the alias' come up with a list
of all Gulliver's Travels in freebase
similarly we take our Gulliver's Travels
from the question and we create an
abstract relation and in simple
questions who wrote co-occurs with book
written by Elmer and buys film story by
and other relations we can take a cross
product that these in these are all
possible interpretations of the question
that we looked at before the some of
them don't make
for example for Gulliver's Travels a
book you wouldn't ask you wouldn't have
the relation film so we just do a filter
on them on which ones we actually find
in freebase and from that we come up
with a list of multiple correct
interpretations of who wrote Gulliver's
Travels for which we have equal
linguistic evidence for each one of
these being correct yet we only have one
ground true for example which is number
three okay so our results we find that
on this widely used benchmark thirty
three point nine percent of the
questions are have multiple correct
interpretations and therefore
unanswerable so in computing the upper
bound we find that not all subject
relations are equal for example in this
case we come up with the relation film
language but we have an option between
two subjects this this one right here
comes up four times in freebase while
this one right here comes up in one and
that distribution allows us to set a
majority upper bound so we've picked
this up subject to relations which
happened most often in freebase and we
find that the best we can do if we
follow that simple baseline is 83.4% on
this data set which is quite close to
the 77% state-of the-art okay then the
second contribution is we're actually
able to get state-of-the-art with just
standard methods with fine tuning so our
baseline model is going to consist of
two neural models the first one is going
to be top case subject recognition which
models the distribution of spans
conditioned on the question secondly
we're going to have a relation
classification model conditioned on the
question and span modeling relation so
to better understand those here is just
an input and output so we want to we
want a film story by to have the largest
probability
in this input same up here so why might
we consider top K because the first
predicted span might not always be
helpful it might not always be in
freebase so we can do a little bit
better by just filtering what is in
freebase and what is not some more
details we use standard CRF tagger top
we use Viterbi inference which is
standard with a CRF tiger we use i/o
tagging glove and beddings and grid
search for hyper parameter optimization
similarly here we use a bioscan with
bachelor-man softmax
we use a MS grad which is the new
version of atom published recently a
fast text and hyper band for hyper
parameter optimization so the results so
these are the past results a lot of
research has been done on this and
boards that I'll introduce this paper or
introduce this data set oh one sec to
give you a little bit of history here
these first these first the first work
done on this was primarily trying to do
an end-to-end method so looking at one
model that can both do relation and
subject classification this these next
two more recent papers we're looking at
baseline approaches of two models and
then these last three papers were all
building custom architectures with three
models at times for various reasons so
then applying the standard approach and
better understanding the data set with
fine tuning we're able to get 78.1%
which is close to our upper bound of
83.4% so finally we want to understand
what is the difference here what what
work is left to be done
so in understanding this we first
considered our first contribution and we
remove we allow for all
interpretations to be correct and that
is 13% of our air to start with then we
found there's a little bit of noise
finally for the remaining air we found
out that there's actually further
ambiguity so our initial analysis was
very static so if there's any small
changes in the sentence at this didn't
catch that didn't catch that ambiguity
so empirical analysis show that our
propound is actually loose due to this
further ambiguity and we find that in
real model airs that most of the work
left on this data set is actually in low
sharp relations where we have less than
10 examples so in concluding due to the
- the first time begin to be found and
due to the further ambiguity we found
there's not much more than 4%
performance left on this data set we
believe secondly we believe it's largely
solved on that simple questions tasks is
largely solved and this is due to the
fact that the remaining the remaining
errors they're mostly due to a lack of
data which is interesting a little bit
yeah all right thank you we can take it
so I mean if the upper bound is that
poor it sounds like there's a good
reason to say maybe we shouldn't just be
returning the top best answer right
maybe it should actually be the best two
or three if specially this is to be used
by it by user I understand why you'd
want the top one to compare to other
systems but I'd be considered like maybe
making an argument to for shared tasks
like maybe we want to look at the top
three best best answers yeah for future
data sets it's definitely important to
acknowledge the issue that sometimes the
top one answer
there could be multiple correct
interpretations yeah I know what
questions you version that you could
have trained this end to end the
relationship classifier and the other
classifier can you elaborate on why you
didn't do that and if you had done it
would you have sold some of the issues
that you were mentioning mm-hmm
we didn't so fundamentally the purpose
or our work was trying to be baseline
and standard so to integrate both
tagging and classification and one model
requires more than baseline work so this
is just the paper first setting the
baseline on this task before thinking
about more custom architectures do you
have any examples that you can show us
today of custom architectures okay I
like the questions you know some some
errors that your D'Amato made and I
don't know I think you show that few
earlier but oh that's fine if you don't
have it that's why I was just are you
talking about
these are yeah yeah okay okay I can send
them to ya no nice for us to see you
yeah you know what kind of areas that
you're missing almost positives maybe
yeah yeah not really a perfect simple
questions archives because they're
multiple answers to the questions that
are listed there should you fix the test
set so that is all simple questions but
it's already all simple questions just
these simple questions tend to
contradict themselves with regards to
which relation they're looking at for
example if we're talking about the book
Gulliver's Travels we might ask what is
the language of Gulliver's Travels if
we're talking about the film Gulliver's
Travels we might
so ask what is the language of
Gulliver's Travels and it's not clear if
you're talking about the book or film
unless you integrate more complexity
into that question or yeah that big us
answer it's still a simple question yeah
a simple question
can't have an ambiguous okay so we have
Yi from you drop again Yi long okay hi
everybody I'm working with Mary and
Hannah I'm going to present our recent
work about a scientific relation
extraction with selectively incorporated
concept embeddings so the reason we are
doing this work is that there are
countless scientific papers published
here and there and the tools that can
manage those scientific knowledge are in
great demand so the task of the the the
goal for this research is that we want
to develop in from information
extraction tools using analog P
approaches that can support scientific
literature so basically we want to build
like scientific knowledge graph and also
we want to answer some specific
scientific search queries so for example
if you ask the computer show me the
masses for Palace fish tagging then the
computer gave us can give us a list of
recommendations of messes that can solve
the problem such a garland syrup and hmm
there are basically two major steps
towards the task of scientific
information extraction so the first one
is scientific contact except extraction
which is first introduced in seminal
2017 and so the task will be to identify
some scientific first bands and also
classify the first band into concept
categories such as method task and
material so for example
the sentence conditional random fields
and named entity recognition will be
extracted and classified as method and
task but the purpose of this paper would
be doing the scientific relation
extraction which is to classify the
relations between the pairs of
scientific concepts so for example in
this sentence we want to know that the
relation between conditional random
field and name and here recognition is
that one concept is used for the other
what so the task is that we want to
given the candidate concept pairs we'll
want to classify them into scientific
relation types so we introduce 5
asymmetric relations which is usage
without model part of and topic and 1
symmetric relation which is comparison
so the data set we use is similar 2018
task 7 which has 500 annotated
scientific abstracts from essay on
astrology the main challenge of this
task is that the annotation is pretty
hard which required to make stupid
expertise so this results in like we
only have limited training data so the
contribution of this research is that we
introduce state-of-the-art neural
relation extraction model to scientific
domain and also we propose a novel
concept selection layer to the neural
structure to mitigate the data scarcity
problem and we obtain the
state-of-the-art result in seminal 2018
task 7 so this is the the overall
structure of our neural relation
extraction model which has merely 4
components so first given this how this
sequence of texts we want to use the
token sequential layer to represent to a
representation for the sequence and then
the representation will be fit into a
concept presentation layer and
dependency sequence layer and then those
representation will be feeding into the
final relation
classification layer and gave us the
final output first the total the token
sequence layer is consists of
bi-directional Alice TM which takes the
input of word embedding and some
featuring matting's and then the
dependencies sequential layer is based
on this representation we passed the
sentence using some steps using some
dependency parser and and then we
extract the shortest path between the
two concepts and then when they come
host the dependency perhaps into two
parts we first find the common ancestor
between the two concepts which is the
word used in this case and then we based
on the direction of the relation we will
model forward dependency path and
backward dependency path which
represents both the concepts the
dependency paths between the concept and
the common ancestor so we would fill in
the head word representation of each
concept and the common ancestor
representation to the backward and
forward dependence it has and then we
would use the representation concatenate
those those tokens as a final
representation for the relation and then
we can output the final result so this
this dependency presentation itself can
already give us pretty good result but
something is like missing in this
structure that is the representation for
the concepts this can model the whole
span of the phrases
the traditional way of doing this is an
example in me want until 2016 which they
automatically learn a weight arfa for
each of the individual token in the
whole concept and then there was some
over the whole of the tokens within the
the concept span the limitation is dis
approaches that without result
introducing any prior knowledge of the
concept the automatically learned
representation will generalize poorly in
the test time so in order to solve that
problem we propose a new approach which
is concept selection so we first
construct a concept dictionary using the
frequent concepts and then learner
appreciating meaningful use of those
concepts and then given a new concept we
will look up through the concept
dictionary and see if there is exact
match for that phrase so if there is is
one exact match for the phrase but we'll
use the pressure and embedding directly
as a concept in writing but if there is
an exact match where would decompose the
phrase into some sub ngrams so for
example here pranaam enou say the
concept comes it candidate its
predominant and Afra resolution but
there is no exact match in the concept
dictionary so we would decompose the
whole phrase into into by grams and
yoonah grams and then we look up those
programs and yoonah grams in the
dictionary and find some matches so here
is the resulting candidates that we
could find which is NFL resolution
resolution and NFL elbow and then we
will use these candidates together with
the MC with a dummy vector
dmt to construct a vector of candidate
sets and then in order to learn the
final representation we need to select
selectively combine all those
representations so in our case
we use attention mechanism to learn wait
between you in each of these embedding
and the the representation in the
sequential layer and then we will sum
over all the ten candidates to get the
final reading the other two to get the
prior for his knowledge we would first
extract all the concepts in large scales
and if it covers using silver the art
scientific term extractor proposed in
2017 and then we use word to back to
train all the frequent concepts and then
construct and then construct this
concept dictionary the dirt that we use
in this task is some of our 2018 task 7
which has three subtasks
so the first subtasks is relation
classification which we assume that
concept pairs and relation deductions
are given so we need to choose between
the six defined relations and the second
task is relation extraction we're given
all the concepts we need to identify if
the relation exists and this is a binary
classification task and the third task
is a relation extraction and
classification task and so when is first
to extract those relations and then
classify them into six relations
together with their directions so the
external data set we use between this
concept embedding as semantic scholar
corpus which has 110 KF structs and the
idea and sorry reference corpus which
has honey to tape some papers so here is
the results so we can our system got the
best result in subtasks 2.1 and we also
did a good job in other two tasks so kim
wan did a little bit better than us but
they use like more civilized data
we'll also perform ablation studies by
removing some of the components of the
neural network so way first sorry
[Music]
so we first remove the dependency layer
which can give us fish wish we could see
that the f1 squirt decrease greatly and
and then we removed this concept there
which also results in a worse
satellite worse f1 score and we also
perform the baseline method which is the
way system of the tokens and this this
might also like didn't perform very well
so the conclusion is that the dependency
informant information is very important
in this task because we don't have a lot
of data and some external knowledge from
the dependency browser is very important
and also the base by Method degrees the
performance we we think like this is
because the a introduce some of
redundant parameters and we also also
find out that replace the span
resonation was selected pre-training the
concept layer would significantly
improve the performance which can give
us the best result of 44.1 so the
summary of this research is that we
introduce a new neural relational model
to scientific domain and we propose a
novel concept selection layer to the
neural structure that can leverage
unlabeled data and also we obtain the
stay of their result in several 2018
touch them yeah so let's hit any
questions
I have one question um if you go to the
experiment so you've mentioned the t1
having a better result and you mentioned
that they used more on they both are
labeled days they both data okay yeah so
they so there are separated in a sense
for different tasks and they're
combining littles data oh I see yeah
because like you're showing that only
the data actually really helps so I was
just yeah there they are using more
civilized data can give me that so good
yeah okay okay okay question okay yeah
thank you
[Applause]